tant parler de cette déclaration du
président de la république que c'était
hier à la réunion ça a fait pas mal de
bruit et si vous l'avez raté la voilà
pour du voile dans l'espace public n'est
pas mon affaire
c'est ça la félicite le port du voile
dans les services publics à l'école
quand on éduque nos enfants c'est mon
affaire je n'aime pas d'ailleurs le
débat qui consiste à stigmatiser qu'un
seul signe religieux
voilà c'est une déclaration qui a
suscité beaucoup de commentaires
approbateurs ou non je vous propose d'en
écouter trois qui sont plutôt critique
on nous allons voir arriver par ordre
d'entrée en scène jordan bardella et
marine le pen du rassemblement national
puis françois-xavier bellamy des
républicains lorsqu'on est chef de
l'état on ne peut pas se défausser de
ses responsabilités
je crois que le voile c'est la sphère de
tous parce que c'est aujourd'hui un fait
de société majeur alors si le voile
n'est pas son aspect son affaire parce
qu'il concerne la soeur publication à la
burqa ce n'est pas non plus son affaire
il est garant de la préservation de la
laïcité qui là encore est un trésor
français et dans le même temps il vient
dire il y a des quartiers entiers dans
lequel il y à un islam politique et au
travers du communautarisme cherche à
faire sécession avec la république et à
sa caisse qu'il apporte comme réponse
rien je m'en lave les mains on aimerait
bien savoir au delà de la question de
savoir ce qui est son affaire ou non
qu'est ce qu'ils proposent véritablement
pour permettre de lutter contre le
communautarisme qui aujourd'hui menace
de fracture et notre société judith
waintraub cette distinction espace
public service public ça a l'air assez
clair par espace public c'est dans la
rue on s'habille comme on veut en
revanche à l'école ou dans une
administration là ça devrait être
différent sauf que c'est le début de
l'intervention d' emmanuel macron et
ensuite il introduit lui même des
éléments de complexité en dix ans
le voile dans l'espace public ce n'est
pas mon affaire un mois à moins que ce
soit un élément de revendications dit il
l'un des signaux d'une forme de
séparatisme
auquel cas ça s'appelle du
communautarisme et c'est mon problème c'
est l' affaire du président de la
république
j'ai l'impression au gré des des
morceaux de phrases et des boues
d'intervention des manuels macron sur ce
sujet qu'en fait il ne fait pas ce
fameux grand discours qu'on attend
quasiment depuis son élection sur la
laïcité parce que il ya une confusion
dans son esprit sur les dangers et les
moyens de les combattre par exemple
quantique dans l'extrait que qu'on a
montré quand il dit je n'aime pas qu'on
stigmatise un seul side religieux est ce
que vous connaissez une autre religion
qu'il ya en france que les que l'islam
qui en france présentent un danger de
radicalisation moi je n'en connais pas
et de radicalisation parfois meurtrières
moi je n'en connais pas le nez les
vielles ce que cette intervention pour
vous est de nature à clarifier le débat
ou à l'apaiser où je pense pas je pense
pas parce que n'est pas effectivement
tout à fait clair dans son propos c'est
comme l'indiqué un jeu dit il
le premier le premier volet indiqué de
la part du président en l'appliquant
gros différenciant ce qui relève de
l'exercice d'une fonction d'une mission
de service public et de ce qui n'en
relève pas par ailleurs qui corresponde
à un peu à l'esprit au global delà de la
laïcité puis après effectivement lundi
compte qu'il peut y avoir
potentiellement des dérives et
potentiellement des affirmations
identitaires qui ne s'inscrivent pas
dans le principe de la réplique ce cas
tourner véritablement les français c'est
d'avoir arriver à définir aujourd'hui ce
qui relève véritablement de l'insertion
dans la république et de tout ce qui
peut relever d'une forme de déclaration
qui serait une forme de déclaration de
cession par rapport à cette manière
qu'on peut être globalement de vivre de
vivre ensemble quand on interroge les
français sur leur rapport général la
pratique de l'islam et au regard qui
peuvent porter à l'égard des musulmans
il déclare que tout ce qui relève en
gros vraiment de la pratique qui
s'expose pas dans l'espace public
globalement ne leur pose pas en tant que
tel et de problèmes que ce soit le fait
de faire cinq prières par jour comme le
fait d'aller à m
etc ou le fait de consommer halal voire
même l'aïd el kébir ne constitue pas en
tant que tel des vrais sujets de tension
la part des françaises et des français
en revanche découle un sentiment qu'on
impose quelque chose regard ou à la
pratique et qui vient entraver ce que
peut être les modalités de vie en commun
là pour le coup on a une forme de
critique extrêmement fortes de la part
de nos compatriotes
est-ce qu'il n'a peut-être pas
complètement tranché le président la
clique dans le cas de sa déclaration
mais parce que j'ai travaillé c'est un
peu subtile de dire dans l'espace public
le voile ne me gêne pas sauf quand il
est un élément de revendications c'est
difficile de faire la différence si
c'était pas aussi grave on aurait ça
après un sketch des inconnus sur les
bons chasseurs et le mauvais chasseur
oui c'est vrai que la formule du
président d'avic frappe son côté assez
générale elle est pas totalement fausse
juridiquement c'est vrai que le voile
attention pas la burqa mais le voile
dans l'espace public n'est que la
manifestation d'une croyance intime sur
laquelle l'état n'a pas de prise le
voile ne serait un problème dans
l'espace public que s'il crée un trouble
à l'ordre public est en réalité ce qui
concerne les pouvoirs publics c'est bien
la burqa vous vous souvenez de la loi
intégrable le voile intégral le niqab
qui couvre le visage qui lui a été
interdit par une loi en 2010 entrée en
vigueur en 2011 une loi sarkozy vous
souvenez peut-être de la phrase
iconiques de la circulaire c'était la
république se vit à visage découvert et
donc on avait à ce titre là interdits et
le conseil constutionnel puis la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme et qui
avait pas de problème puisque on ne peut
pas y aller il ya pour le coup après
d'ordre public a caché son visage dans
l'espace public donc il faut bien faire
en effet la différence entre le niqab
qui lui intéresse totalement les
pouvoirs publics et le voile malgré tout
on voit bien que c'est ta voix du
juridique la distinction qui se fait et
est assez pertinente puisque en effet
l'administration orale et le pouvoir
politique a à dire sur le voile pour ces
agents publics et dans les services
publics en effet dans la rue tant que ça
ne crée pas un trouble à l'ordre public
c'est autorisé maintenant qu'ils ne
voient que derrière le petit bout de la
lorgnette juridique
il ya aussi un problème énorme politique
qui se pose est dire que le président de
la république n'a rien à dire
sur le voie et dans l'espace public
c'est quand même aller très loin et
ignorer que c'est quand même un symptôme
alors j'irai pas aussi loin que judith
sur le fait que l'islam est la seule
religion qui pose problème en france il
ya d'autres possibilités d'autres non
mais j'attends il yad'autres
radicalisation qui pose aussi des
problèmes entre en religion
oui d'autres reliques alister religieuse
qui pose aussi des problèmes mais malgré
tout ce qu'on voit pas l'attentât en
tout cas je sais pas est totalement
exact mais en tout état de cause je dis
bien que l'affirmation est sans doute
trop large et trop abrupte elle est
peut-être juridiquement exact n'est
socialement elle est difficilement
acceptable oui évidemment la présence de
voiles est un symptôme de la présence
d'une religion musulmane dans la france
auquel à laquelle l'état ne peut pas
être complètement insensible mais c'est
pas ça le problème c'est pas le problème
c'est pas la religion musulmane
un tiers seulement des femmes musulmanes
sont voilées donc je veux pas dire non
mais voyez le fait d'ignorer la présence
du voile et de dire que ça ne le regarde
pas en tant que président de la
république est quand même compliquée des
façons de s'en laver les mains un peu
oui c'est une façon de s'en laver les
mains alors encore une fois
juridiquement c'est audible après
politiquement c'est quand même plus
contestable le lévis on sait que ce
voile c'est un élément de crispation la
société française on voit la même chose
en italie a le même type de débat ou
bien ça pose pas de problème ah non
c'est un non sujet mais c'est un non
sujet plus ou moins dans tous les pays
voisins de la france et je dirais même
en occident c'est vraiment un non sujet
depuis des années en france ou si je
pense que ça devrait être un non sujet
c'est à dire que qu'au départ il ya
trente ans il y avait encore le mur de
berlin
c'était très intéressant quand le
premier cas des étudiantes a explosé
s'était effectivement un débat hyper
intéressant et qui comportait une
dimension sociale religieuse politique
et tout le monde sont intéressés après
il ya eu des lois qui ont été établies
et depuis
voilà les choses sont claires ce qu'a
répété aujourd'hui le président de la
république cette distinction qu'il a
fait est d'une banalité criant c'est à
dire simplement traduit en mots ce qui
est écrit inscrit dans la loi c'est à
dire que le voile est interdit à juste
titre selon le législateur français dans
les écoles parce que quand on est gamin
on les plus sensibles et donc il faut
être protégé après je pense en vivant
ici en france depuis déjà quelques
années qu'il y a dans ce pays une
confusion de fond sur la définition même
de laïcité parce que là tous les pays on
dirait que parfois la laïcité c'est une
exclusivité française dans tous nos pays
en europe sont inscrits l'a décidé dans
l'eure dans leur constitution et dans
tous les pays disons la définition c'est
liberté de penser et de croire ou de ne
pas croire et surtout la religion le
religieux ne doit pas intervenir dans
les affaires de l'état et l'état ne doit
pas intervenir dans les affaires
religieuses
ça c'est là la définition qu'on entend
partout et qui est aussi la définition
française qu'on trouve dans les textes
après il ya une autre définition qu
spécifique à la france ce qu'on appelle
la laïcité à la française qui voudrait
que cette laïcité soit plus active trois
actifs presque militante et donc c'est
cette laïcité que si par exemple marine
le pen selon laquelle des individus ne
pourrait pas sortir dans la rue dans
l'espace public avec un mois
chose qui est complètement en
contradiction avec le principe clé de
nos démocraties occidentales c'est à
dire le libre arbitre
parce que on ouvre on ouvrirait la
impôts de pandore incroyable
nos internautes sont 76% à considérer qu
emmanuel macron à tort de considérer que
le port du voile dans l'espace public
n'est pas son affaire je précise tout de
suite surtout en présence de jean launay
lewicki s'agit pas d'un sondage mais
sont les internautes qui sont en train
de nous suivre et qui réagit sur twitter
s'agit donc pas d'un échantillon
représentatif si ce n'est des gens
ayant le bon goût de suivre point de vue
et puis y'a nicole qui nous dit le voile
est un élément de séparation il ya kaya
le corps on ne prescrit pas le port du
voile
il n'est qu'une affirmation provocatrice
identitaire puis pâtit ce qu'ils nous
disent c'est le devoir de macron de
protéger la france contre toute forme de
communautarisme prenant d'autres valeurs
que celles de la république
on a quand même le sentiment jean daniel
lévy que il peut pas y avoir de
consensus sur ce sujet parce que parce
que tant que derrière le voile certains
voient une liberté individuelle et
d'autre une forme de communautarisme
hostiles au vivre ensemble c'est tout
c'est la subjectivité et puis et puis on
en reste là il va y avoir de consensus
il papa il va d'ailleurs du consensus
même dans le groupe quand vous regardez
parlementaires à l'international de la
réplique en marche ou même au sein du
gouvernement
ce qui est intéressant c'est que c'est
un sujet qui a été pour partie délaissée
par le président a rappelé que lorsqu'il
était encore peint électorale qui
n'avait pas été tranchée et en tout cas
fait partie du pacte présidentiel et qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui
lorsqu'il est confronté à une situation
qu une situation sur laquelle n'y avait
pas eu de consensus même au sein de sa
formation politique préalable
cette majorité se déchire en france on
n'arrivera pas à un consensus qu'on
n'arrivera pas à un consensus pour
savoir globalement où commence la
liberté où s'arrête pour preuve pour
faire vite
également cette forme de liberté dans
quelle mesure on peut considérer le
voile en tant qu elle malgré tout il ya
toujours besoin d'avoir une prise de
parole qui est une prise par le forte il
ya besoin d'avoir des orientations qui
vient de définir concrètement
effectivement ce qu'est la laïcité
quelles interprétations ont fait de la
laïcité aujourd'hui est ce que les
termes qui avait été posée en 1905 qui
était quand même radicalement différent
parce qu'on a c'est qu'en face à
l'église catholique avec des
interrogations notamment sur des
questions de financement et pas
uniquement d'exercice du culte en tant
que tel qui étaient posées sont
aujourd'hui ou pas encore d'actualité et
c'est vrai que on voit bien et vous
l'avez rappelé il ya pas eu de discours
fort de la part du président de la
république depuis qu'il est en exercice
il y en a même pas eu préalablement il
n'y a pas eu des cris il n'y a même pas
une forme de doxa qui seraient celles
traditionnelles qui serait portée par la
formation politique dont il répare donc
autour de ça on va vivre avec des
sentiments des émotions des
représentations et pas forcément une
représentation de ce qu'est aujourd'hui
la définit
de la place de l'état et du regard qui
est porté à l'égard de ce sujet lorsque
le président l'appliquent dit ça ne me
regarde pas les français disent comme ça
devient aujourd'hui un sujet de société
et un enjeu même de valeur de ce que
peut être la société française forcément
le président applique est appelé à se
prononcer à dire concrètement ce que
peut être sa position le danger c'est le
vin trop que ce soit compris comme une
forme de naïveté du président de dire
c'est pas mon affaire
un petit peu comme quand alain juppé
avait parlé d' identité heureuse pour
parler de la france je trouve pas ce que
l'identité heureuse c'était une position
rappelez vous avez un objectif aussi
juppé parler d'identité heureuse ça
c'était l'objectif et le moyen c'était
les accommodements raisonnables phrase
qui d'ailleurs que les vrais noms c'est
chez nous au figaro et qui lui avait
collé à l'aspect pendant toute la
campagne des primaires et pas au delà
puisque pour lui ça s'était arrêté là
non alain juppé a eu le mérite de
prendre une position qu'on peut trouver
critiquable je l'avais trouvé
critiquable à l'époque mais mais il l'a
fait emmanuel macron c'est pire une pro
pas de position j'en ai dit elle vient
de le rappeler et ça dure depuis son
élection il donne des éléments qui vont
dans un sens dans un autre dans un débat
qui comptera vrai ce que vous dites
agite beaucoup de nos voisins européens
je pense à la belgique par exemple je
pense à l'allemagne aussi on n'est pas
les seuls au monde à s'inquiéter de voir
apparaître des signes de radicalisation
c'est vrai que quand je vous invite à
les gens voient très très peu
apparemment c'est très mal admis dans la
société italienne ou peut-être qu'il ya
moins la composition radicalisation de
l'être c'est ce que vient de dire macro
que vous trouviez
edit parfois lentement c'est parfois un
élément de revendications l'instrument
d'une forme de séparatisme
mais tout est dans le parfois et
politiquement je peux pas dire ça en
principe oui on peut pas généraliser
voilà ça peut l'être ça peut évidemment
ne pas l'être dans l'immense majorité
des cas après le risque qui est une
série bien sûr bon bref il le risque
c'est qu'ils aient une forme de hiatus
entre la position du président a fui et
le ressenti des français c'est ça c'est
l'idée d'un décalage entre cette
présence du voile qui est perçu par
certains français à tort ou à raison
comme un problème social et le président
de la république qui se retire sur
l'aventin en disant moi c'est pas mon
problème
cela étant dit il est pas tout à fait
vrai de dire qu'il ne s'est jamais
exprimé sur la question de la laïcité ou
de la religion il a quand même eu son
discours des bernardins qui était quand
même un discours important donc il sait
déjà un peu exprimés mais c'est vrai que
il a lui-même fait attendre une prise de
parole forte sur la question de laïcité
et en l'état on l'attend toujours
il s'est pas cette interview là qui va
dissiper les malentendus
j'ai l'impression que cette prise de
parole a été plutôt réclamé que que que
rien d'autre
mais surtout la chose curieuse c'est le
fait est ce qu'on demande à tous les
présidents de la république de
s'exprimer ne sait pas sur la loi du 10
mars sur le mariage bord surtout des
lois de société qu'ils sont déjà passés
c'est pas son affaire il y a des lois
qui ont déjà été ça n'a rien à voir avec
le port du voile pardon mais ces deux
thèmes et ne faut pas faire d'amalgamé
ces deux thèmes complètement estimé la
chose curieuse c'est que on demande un
président de la cour complètement y
règne peut-être mais j'en suis persuadé
la seule chose que je me permettais de
de constater très modestement c'est
qu'on demande à un président de la
république d'intervenir sur un thème qui
est déjà inscrit dans les lois et que
personne ne remet en cause
et alors je me demande être pourquoi ne
pas lui demander aussi d'intervenir sur
le divorce sur le mariage porto ce sera
l'arrivée les fonds soient naturels à
faire des sorties scolaires avons
évidemment sur le devant de la scène
cette question
de façon très forte la france est comme
profondément travailler pour autour de
cette notion en question qui sommes-nous
qu'est ce qu'être français aujourd'hui
quelle est la spécificité française
même si vous avez indiqué que la laïcité
n'était pas présent plan france ça reste
aujourd'hui une ossature extrêmement
forte
aujourd'hui au sein de la population
française et quand on demande
globalement aux français ce qu'il fait
la spécificité française par rapport à
d'autres types de pays souvent en dehors
évidemment de la gastronomie de
l'architecturé cetera on va nous parler
de points que ce n'est point sensible
notamment les thématiques de la laïcité
et que ce bois là est un point qui agite
globalement l'ensemble de la cité
française au moins depuis 1989
on se rappelle avec les débats autour du
port du voile de la part de trois jeunes
filles au sein de l'établissement de
l'utiliser mais depuis qui revient de
manière assez récurrente pour savoir
justement fait qu'elle ait cette
articulation que l'on peut avoir
aujourd'hui entre la reconnaissance de
la pratique des cultes qui relève en
fait de la pratique individuelle et
l'amiante on peut vivre collectivement
et c'est vrai que cette question se pose
notamment et puis notamment parce qu'il
ya de plus en plus malgré tout deux
personnes qui portent le voile dans
l'espace public français
merci beaucoup je suis sûr que c'est un
sujet dont on nous serons amenés à
reparler voici 2 commentaires pour finir
celui d hôpital qui nous dit la question
qui doit se poser c'est pourquoi ce type
de problème ne se posait pas dans les
années 70 c'est depuis cette réaction de
babineau emmanuel macron s'exprime sans
prendre position
il reste